la taille fait la différence
ma mère m'a toujours dit tout est
question de taille dans la vie alors
venant d'une femme c'est énorme
aujourd'hui de vouloir vous convaincre
que l'infiniment petit peu changé la vie
alors les nanoparticules de quoi il
s'agit vous savez j'espère que oui parce
que pendant dix minutes je vais vous en
parler alors vous voyez ce pub il fait 1
cm de côté si vous coupez
ce cube en un million de petits segments
et que vous prenez un petit segment
ça représente une nanoparticule de dix
nanomètres
ces nanoparticules sont présentes
partout dans notre environnement et
pourrait révolutionner notre société
l'or vous connaissez ce matériau et bien
saviez vous que cette inerte
biocompatible inaltérable et qu'il ne
s'oxyde ni dans l'air ni dans l'eau ce
qui lui procure en fait cet éclat doré
tant convoité par toutes les
civilisations depuis la nuit des temps
et bien lors à l'échelle de la
nanoparticule revêt des propriétés
physico-chimiques extraordinaire des
propriétés que l'on peut exploiter dans
le secteur de l'environnement la défense
le bâtiment la cosmétique ou la santé
alors vous dites pourquoi je vous parle
aujourd'hui de nanoparticules
avant de répondre à cette question
permettez moi de me présenter
donc je suis anne laure réunionnaise et
d'un père réunionnais et d'une mère
bordelaise j'ai vécu vingt ans la vie
ici à la réunion et 12 ans partagé entre
la région bordelaise paris la réunion
ma vie d'étudiante a été ponctuée par
les voyages dès que l'occasion se
présentait mais j'étais donc attaché à
mes racines réunionnaises est partagé
entre l' envie de rentrer pour retrouver
les miens et partir pour apprendre
découvrir m'enrichir pour pouvoir mieux
revenir
donc je suis parti étudier les sciences
la biologie d'abord pour comprendre le
corps humain est l'échelle de la cellule
briques constitutive de notre corps à
l'échelle de la molécule et je me suis
passionné pour les réactions
biochimiques
donc je visualise la vie au travers de
cycles biochimiques qui se croisent et
se mélange un peu comme ça c'est beau
non
c'est un peu ce qu'il ya dans ma tête
actuellement mais on ne peut plus
organiser en fait je me posais plein de
questions
alors comment les macromolécules
peuvent-elles se mouvoir en solutions
vous savez ce fameux mouvement brownien
dont tout le monde parle c'est comment
comprendre les mécanismes à l'échelle
moléculaire
en fait pour moi ça revenait à étudier
les tous premiers stades de la création
de la vie au niveau de l'atome
l'élément fondamental et ça me
permettait de remonter jusqu'à sa
complexification pourquoi l'atome s'est
il fixé sur une matière inerte qu'elle
était
force et les liaisons mise en jeu alors
au cours de mes expériences en
laboratoire
j'ai croisé des chercheurs des
chercheurs qui force l'admiration
cela va de la caricature du savant fou
qui est prêt à faire exploser le
laboratoire un enseignant cherche dont
la préoccupation première est de
transmettre une passion celle des
sciences aux jeunes dans l'espoir de
semer la future graine de prix nobel
alors j'apprends les codes en
laboratoire le fameux rituel thé café
pendant deux heures avant de l'être la
blouse j'apprends des méthodologies de
travail la recherche par la recherche
par essais et erreurs
un état d'esprit l'absence de dogme
l'ouverture la remise en question
perpétuelle et j'accède un environnement
qui me fascine je me rappelle de mon
premier professeur de chimie organique
qui portait la blouse blanche du matin
au soir
pourquoi par respect pour les sciences
par respect pour tous ceux qui
continuent à espérer qu'ils attendent
des avancées les sciences représente
pour moi un moyen de comprendre les
interactions entre le vivant et l'inerte
inter action une action qui s'établit
entre deux corps entre deux solides
entre deux matériaux je me souviens
avoir buté très souvent sur ce terme
interactions allez on remet ça s'écrit
peur avec un et mais avec un e
alors pourquoi ai-je ajouté un accent à
ce e comme une envie de mettre de la
ponctuation dans une phrase pour rythmer
mettre un peu de coeur dans ce qui
pourrait manquer comment donner du sens
à ce que je faisais en sciences je me
revois petit
sise à côté de mon grand père dimanche
après-midi après le déjeuner il dit onze
enfants quoi vous faire plus tard sauvé
ce papy ma soeur aussi on est à
l'aéroport c'est le premier grand départ
pour la métropole je viens d'avoir mon
bac toute la famille est là c'est chargé
en émotion j'ai la gorge nouée
je retiens mes larmes uniquement pour
mon voisin dans l'avion hélas ma soeur
me glisse un message dans la poche que
je découvre une fois le filtre de police
passait et à me dis alors sois fier de
ce que tu entreprends et soit heureuse
alors cette phrase marque le début de ma
recherche professionnelle après ma thèse
j'ai travaillé en fiscalité de la
recherche crédit d'impôt recherche
waouh super marketing de l'innovation
réalisation d'études de marché
diversification d'activités pour des
laboratoires des chefs d'entreprise
toujours pour aider à valoriser au mieux
le fruit de la recherche académique
espère en faisant aboutir en fait des
molécules dormantes et pour comprendre
ces chefs d'entreprise comprendre la
recherche et enfin établir ou rétablir
un lien entre ces deux mondes
c'est au contact des chefs d'entreprise
que je comprends ma vocation
je m'inspire de cette énergie ce courage
cette force c'est indéfinissable énergie
qui les animent au quotidien
je puise alors dans leur sourire la
force la détermination pour exister
écrire mon projet celui d'établir le
lien entre donc le business et les
sciences je me qualifie d'entrepreneuses
scientifique chimiste de formation les
pieds sur terre et la tête dans les
étoiles le coeur dans l'infiniment en
grand pour et mails infiniment petit à
ce moment là je porte un projet fou
celui de fabriquer des nanoparticules
oui les petits objets dont je vous ai
parlé tout à l'heure pour révolutionner
le traitement du cancer
mais je m'autocensure d'entrée de jeu
non trop long trop coûteux et puis de
toute façon à la réunion il n'existe
aucun dispositif permettant de
caractériser ses échantillons
imaginez la difficulté pour visualiser
un milliardième de mètre oui je regagne
la terre de mes ancêtres et je
redécouvre mon île par le prisme des
sciences d'abord aux côtés des chefs
d'entreprise en santé valorisation de la
biodiversité protection de
l'environnement
les plantes et les organismes marins et
occupe une place importante
et vous savez quoi on parle pour la
première fois d'un enregistrement de
plantes réunionnaise à la pharmacopée
française
et là c'est un déclic
oui la réunion terre d'avenir
je ressens une immense fierté pour tous
ces scientifiques qui ont contribué à
cette réussite
j'y vois le rapprochement entre les
tisaneurs les pharmaciens les chefs
d'entreprise les scientifiques un pont
entre la recherche et le business les
acteurs socio-économiques et là tout
devient
cible je me remet à rêver un sujet me
touche particulièrement le cancer j'ai
perdu des proches amis famille et
certains combattent encore ce fléau vous
avez tous connus
autour de vous des proches ayant subi
ces traitements
vous les connaissez radiothérapie
chimiothérapie des molécules toxiques
injecté qui tue tout tout sur leur
passage
parce qu'elles sont toxiques pour les
cellules tumorales mais aussi pour les
îles hussein mais on continue à les
injecter aux patients en leur promettant
parfois une destruction totale du cancer
je suis en colère
vraiment on demande aux patients de
garder un moral d'acier et de trouver la
force pour supporter les douleurs les
changements physiques mais que faisons
nous que font ces scientifiques et
publié publié publie il parle de
traitement révolutionnaire contre le
cancer
mais où sont ces traitements où sont ils
le scientifique doit revêtir sa cape
d'entreprise de chef d'entreprise parce
que c'est ainsi que le combat contre les
maladies graves pourra être mené
je puise chaque jour cette énergie pour
écrire mon projet pour faire aboutir ce
traitement révolutionnaire alors je
rédige ce projet je le soumets à un
concours je remporte le premier prix est
un financement
je parviens à établir des partenariats
avec chaque spécialiste des étapes de
mon projet la toile se tisse peu à peu
créer ma start up en biotech et la
petite réunionnaise que je suis va créer
trois emplois l'année prochaine sur le
territoire réunionnais j'espère que ces
nanoparticules vont pouvoir
révolutionner le traitement du cancer
j'ai réussi à établir des partenariats à
la réunion paris demain les états unis
l'asie le monde on parle de
nanotechnologies pour la première fois à
la réunion et j'ai réussi à utiliser des
extraits de plantes de la réunion pour
fabriquer de nanoparticules et vous
savez quoi
j'ai réussi à les visualiser ces
nanoparticules je suis une nanoparticule
vous êtes des nanoparticules de ce grand
corps qu'est le monde
mon action notre action peut changer le
monde